merci et l'on ne dira pas ce soir que
l'image vampirise les mots claude
lelouch a décidé d'adapter les
misérables de victor hugo
mais il est vrai qu'il le fait librement
très librement tournage du tournage
c'est une exclusivité grâce à pascal
deschamps bernard connors qui se sont
intéressés aux nouveaux emballages en cd
belle imaginer un jour de novembre 1918
une cour d'infirmerie militaire et près
de trente ans qu'elle casse et qui
trompent leur ennui et leur peur au pied
d'un ring de fortune
ils ne le savent pas encore c'est quoi
lui blessé mais nous sommes à quelques
heures de la fin de la guerre
et comme le dit claude lelouch c'est de
la grande foule des petits les sans
grades des misérables que claude lelouch
je veux raconter l'histoire avec humour
et tendresse
lui qui entendit parler du livre pour la
première fois en 43
lorsque sa mère fuyait les allemands la
contrôleur qui contrôlent l éthique et
les paupières qui rentre dans le
compartiment et qui s'aperçoit que les
papiers de la mer était pas n'est pas
claire quoi j'ai vu ma mère pour acheter
son silence lui donner ça montre quand
le contrôleur est parti elle a dit
qu'elle thénardier alors je vous qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un thénardier et ensuite
pendant la nuit ma mère pour la première
fois à essayer de me raconter les
misérables dans ce coin de france qui
détient les records de froid le journal
jean claude lelouch jean paul belmondo
comment ce siècle au bagne comme celui
du roman modestement claude lelouch se
met dans la peau d'un victor hugo qui
serait né avec le cinéma et raconterait
en images le destin d'un homme comme les
autres qui traverserait le siet ses
tourments voilà pour les grands milieu
du récit sur les détails restent muets
et malgré notre insistance on avons pu
arracher de confidences à ses comédiens
et pourquoi donc parce que claude a mis
en garde les secrets et aussi parce que
parce que je ne le sais pas y'a que
claude qui sait vraiment ce qui se passe
dans ce scénario c'est ça qui fait qu il
fait aussi son charme des ponts dix
s'est improvisé alors les gens pensent
qu'un lien avec les 7 et riz
formidablement et après enfin de presser
haut les nous demande de pâtes ou les
coudes et dans certaines fois
d'improviser et et comme il a un très
bon oeil
il va choisir les bonnes choses qui
arrivent dans cette improvisation
séances d'improvisation donc dans le
dortoir du bagne ce jour là face à jean
paul belmondo
il y à un prisonnier tout nouveau dans
le métier que vous avez deux secondes
pour reconnaître
jouer en face d'un un débutant qui
s'appelle belmondo on se dit ah ça va
faire ça fait ça fait ça c'est épuisant
voilà il ya aussi jean marais nicole
croisille annie girardot michel boujenah
ou philippe léotard tous ont dit oui à
lelouch oui l aventure qui les mènera
jusqu'au moment où les personnages ne
souhaiteront pas une bonne année les un
bon siècle